[Music]
in many ways the interventional Ukraine
by Russia was in reflection of the
observation well the West was weaker
I mean perceived in the past
the first intervention in Ukraine came
not from Russia but from the West Russia
is responding to Western intervention
China a country which is also
multi-ethnic but historically has its
own borders which should be
internationally respected should be one
shouldn't that be the same for Ukraine
as well which is also internationally
recognized as a single sovereign nation
with territorial borders
is it a Gathering Storm if China gains
more power and China and Russia maybe
India gain more power at the expense of
America is this a storm is something we
should on the whole be scared of so is
this something we should be scared of or
is it something we should welcome
if the heresy is it's something we
should welcome I think we'll find this
well represented by George Galloway on
my right
he's an MP for respect and he described
his 2012 return to office as the most
sensational victory in British history
Winston Churchill might have disagreed
with that I suppose Ron and mr. on my
left is presenter of radio threes free
thinking and a contributor to the FT but
his main job is professor of the history
and politics of modern China at Oxford
and Stephen King here on my right is
global chief economist at HSBC a former
columnist at the independent join the
club and his most recent book is when
the money runs out the end of Western
affluence and I should have said at the
beginning my name's Marianne C cart and
I'm also journalist and broadcaster
the Gathering Storm is apt title given
the weather outside but I don't see it
globally as a Gathering Storm at all as
Marianne has correctly signaled we had a
unipolar world for more than a decade
dominated by a giant with the mind of a
child or at least its president had the
mind of a child on the edge of an
facility but containing all the Rockets
and all the power and it was a truly
terrifying era and we're lucky that we
emerged from it but the power is now in
transformation the United States is hard
power is still very hard to be sure but
its soft power and its economic power is
in decline relatively and in fact
absolutely and the new powers the new
polls that Marianne has mentioned there
are others though Turkey is potentially
a powerful Pole Iran is South Africa is
and India of course is well on its way
to being a super power and I think that
will make the world far safer because a
multi polar world is one in which people
have to negotiate rather than reaching
for their rockets and striding out
across the globe as they please like the
famous I just interviewed Noam Chomsky
so I'm reminded of his recall of of the
the encounter between Alexander the
Great and a pirate captain on the high
seas and st. Augustine city of God in
which Alexander asks the pirate how dare
you terrorize these waters as a thief
and the pirate answers how dare you
terrorize the whole world you with your
great navy can call yourself an emperor
and can call other men as you please and
that was the era to which we
turn in the unipolar period when George
Bush was in charge George Bush and Tony
Blair I'm making a film about him by the
way called the killing of Tony Blair
you'll enjoy it I promise it doesn't
involve me killing Tony Blair but that
would be an even more popular movie so I
welcome this new era of course that's
not to endorse every every aspect of
these new powers I have criticisms of
actually all of them including the
United States but it will be a much
safer and better world if the United
Nations becomes a meaningful place again
with the powers the new powers and the
old having to negotiate their way
through international difficulties
I think when we think about what these
powers are some of the very important
points that George has made some of
which I would agree with entirely I
think do you begin to look a little bit
lacking in salinity let me tell you
briefly what happened when I spoke to a
friend of mine who's an economists he's
Chinese based in China at quite a high
level Research Institute secretly he is
in fact a great fan in fact of george w
bush and of evangelical christianity he
doesn't tend to mention this very much
at Chinese Communist Party meeting
however when I spoke to him recently
about China's prospects and where the
economy is going how many patients who
said to me look Rana and the way you are
asking me these questions because I can
tell you the Chinese system is going to
collapse in five years from now I
thought for me I said yes but my friend
I remember I met me first ten years ago
and you told me then that China was
going to collapse in five years and I
know it's five years beyond that he
thought again and said yes I do remember
honor that I did tell you that but this
time I am right there is a danger I
think in trying to project forwards
where we are now in a linear sort of way
but I think that nonetheless I think
what that little story says yes is that
actually in a sense arguing that things
are going to change in a very obvious
direction can be a bit of a monk's game
and China is a place which I think when
looked at closely has so many flaws and
so many difficulties that giving it
greater status in the world is actually
going to create more problems that I
think it is solutions let's look in
particular at the way in which China has
started behaving as it moves towards the
kind of multipolar world that George has
been talking about it is a country that
in the language of the play round is
Billy no-mates or should that should be
Jiang Shi no-mates I imagine in other
words if you have to think of countries
around the world which have a genuine
close
sense of Alliance and affinity with
China you've got Cambodia not Maria
North Korea maybe Pakistan I mean these
might figures you want to take with you
to a knife fight but in terms of
bringing the United Nations this is not
the posse they want to be seen I thought
Russia was their new best friends right
let me just go into that very briefly
for a second basically Russia has a lot
of oil and gas China needs a lot of oil
and gas if they have been such good
friends I would like to know why Vlad
Putin had to sign the oil gas 200
billion dollar cooperation agreement at
four o'clock in the morning it suggests
that this was the product some pretty
hardline bargaining between these two
when I spoke to a Chinese didn't matter
actually a couple of weeks ago about
this question she just said the thing is
you have to remember that China has been
sorry Russia has been trying to invade
China for a lot longer than America has
and our historical memories bring that
to bring that to mind just come back
briefly today at the point about the
multipolar world though China has been
entirely unsuccessful it seems to me in
terms of creating a narrative around
itself that people want to align to the
United States has allies of some
standing one can argue and I think will
argue about how real those alliances are
but Japan Taiwan South Korea are all
countries that have some real and full
affinity to an American dominated order
in East Asia even more bizarrely to
anyone remembers the the era of 30 or 40
years ago Vietnam is now by default an
American ally in that kind of context I
simply think whether we think it's a
good thing or a bad thing is almost
irrelevant the facts on the ground and
the facts on the seas are that China has
become the kind of careless in some ways
blundering power unable to use and
direct kind of economic might that it's
developed to develop genuine stable
multilateral alliance in is in Asia and
I have the fear that if that would have
become more powerful then we might look
back on the days of george w bush
politician whose talents i think i
probably share the opinion that george
has on in in general as a time of peace
harmony and possibly you know a meta
Nietzschean or bhisma here sense of
statesmanship which we will all be or be
or we highly nostalgic thank you your
honor
well first of all I my impression was
that we had a rather multipolar world
back in about 1913 1914 to it with the
end very happily so I just raised that
as a good point a broad issue about
multiplayer worlds and secondly I think
that's as far as China is concerned the
economics of China have advanced hugely
relative to China's international
political relations with the rest of the
world is economic powers undoubted if
you look at term China back in 1980 it's
living standards with the equivalent of
those in the US everything around about
seventeen seventy by 2010 is living
standards up to those in the US in a row
at 1940 this has been an epic
transformation of an economy the
relatively short space of time never
seen anything quite like that for an
economy with such a large population the
problem I think for China is this that
as runner I think indicated there needs
to be a very strong sense in China they
have to provide connections with the
rest of the world particulars
it's not just Russia in sub-saharan
Africa is Latin America and so on
and one of the big challenge that China
has is that the infrastructure that
currently exists within those countries
is relatively poor up until now the
Chinese to be mostly investing in things
like US Treasuries in the future they've
been investing I think increasingly in
these countries but then the question is
how do they safeguard those investments
in the future and I did hear of a little
historical lesson which is the rise of
the British East India Company which was
ultimately a originally a commercial
enterprise and eventually became a key
part of the growth of the British Empire
almost by accident rather than by design
in a sense that the British East India
Company ended up with the mercenary army
which became eventually part of the
British Army and that then led to
Britain spreading its empire far and
wide and my concern with China in one
sense is it yes it makes these
tremendous investments elsewhere it
needs to do so but in looking how to
protect them
it creates a bigger military force over
the course of next 10 20 30 years and in
the process challenges the u.s. in terms
of its presence elsewhere in the world
whether across other parts of Asia or in
recently in parts of America's own
backyard I think about for example Latin
America about the Monroe Doctrine of the
1820s this was originally suggesting
that the US would have control over
Latin America against the interests of
the Europeans but when the Chinese
started investing much more in Latin
America how does that doctrine work in
terms of America's relationship to China
so I think that as China grows it hasn't
worked out yet what its foreign policy
should be it's still very round the
circle but in the process of growing it
seems to me that it creates shockwaves
elsewhere in the world which the rest of
us haven't quite worked out how to deal
with
George you seem to be in favor of a move
towards China having more power in the
u.s. less power and yet you're talking
about a country which allies itself at
North Korea with Iran and I mean only
this week actually vetoed a Security
Council resolutions saying that both
sides in the Syrian conflict ought to be
taken to the ICC for war crimes so why
would we want to cut you like that
dominating the world you see I said in
life on Mars you see that as if it's a
bad thing you see you look at the world
from an entirely different standpoint to
me I'm not an expert on China as our two
friends are I don't make my living
watching and criticizing China but I
know two things first of all that China
isn't going to collapse in five years
though it's extremely worrying if such a
high ranking member of the Chinese
establishment is regularly predicting
that to you
in fact China's progress is bolted and
the the prospects for China are
extremely rosy indeed I would that we
had such prospects as they do and the
second thing I know is that they know
very well what their foreign policy is
and it is as you've just described it in
a derogatory way it is that we will not
allow you to go around the world bombing
people in the way that you did in that
golden age you imagine we'll all be
harking back to but the French ones
suggesting we home Syria the French were
suggesting we should deal with human
rights yet you haven't William he called
the French sorry the Chinese Foreign
Minister in the run-up to the vote in
the House of Commons last August where
we stopped by a majority of 13 a war
with Syria and by extension Iran with
Russia and China on the other side of
that war I think you should be grateful
to the House of Commons that we have for
having done that but William Hague
called the Chinese foreign minister who
wouldn't come to the phone but he sent
one of his fact totems to the phone to
tell mr. hey there is no point in a
condo
there are no circumstances in which
China will support an attack on Syria so
Chinese that's the Chinese foreign
policy a rejection of the neocon warlike
foreign policy that we have suffered
through this unipolar world over this
last period but I take off to China's
foreign policy
are you suggesting that the Chinese
actually stopped the war in Syria no it
was just their opinion no one no sir mr.
Haig was phoning them to get them to
support an attack on Syria right and
this they wouldn't even talk to him they
said there are no circumstances in which
we will support an attack on Syria so
that seems like a very clear foreign
policy to me you don't like it no they
don't have one it's that you don't like
what I did like is them preventing
terrible war crimes and human rights
abuses being investigated why is that do
you think because the war crimes are
committed in a war supported by you
supported by your newspaper by countries
that you think are wonderful and so the
way to stop the war crimes in Syria is
to stop the war in Syria stop fueling it
stop sending our kind of fanatics to
into destroying Syria stop giving them
money and guns but George even if the
Chinese are producing such a skilled
form of diplomacy on the question at
that part of the Islamic world why just
this week and many time times in the
last few months and years have there
been so many attacks from the Muslim
Uighur population in the west of China
on Chinese official sources this doesn't
suggest the kind of skill diplomacy and
engagement that you're talking about
China had a consistent forum post the
wiggers my dear are not a foreign policy
issue there are domestic policy issues
that France nothing is sinking is a
province of China and though some of you
would quite like
you'll forgive the pun to make the
weaker question and Sinkiang a [ __ ] in
china's armour it's not going to be
allowed to be China is one and it will
defend its borders and it will defend
its unity however much is the wish of
Western liberals in Tibet or Islamists
in sync yang or dreamers on the
international level who imagine China's
going to collapse however much you like
it let me give you a quote from don't
chomping who told Prince Charles who
sotto voce gave him some advice on how
to handle Hong Kong which we took from
China under bombardment because they
wouldn't allow us to sell narcotic drugs
in their country he said to Prince
Charles the days when foreigners could
tell China what to do are over
hallelujah
pastor George one thing on Syria I think
is important to note is that well though
China may have a particular view on
Syria I think Russia took the story on
Syria in a very different way indeed
they took the view that the failure of
the UK or the u.s. to intervene in Syria
was actually a significant sign of
weakness of the US in the UK but they
actually lost their willingness to
intervene in these kinds of foreign wars
which may or may not be a good thing but
the consequence was that I think Russia
felt as a consequence of that to be able
to launch a much more assertive foreign
policy and having the case of install
then so in many ways the interventional
Ukraine by Russia was in reflection of
the observation well the West was weaker
I mean perceived in the past so again
but this multiple well actually seems to
me to be rather an unstable rather than
stable were the first intervention in
Ukraine came not from Russia but from
the West Russia is responding to Western
intervention not many to attention well
it's every kind of intervention
according to Victoria Nuland who should
know as she was the ambassador and is
now at the State Department dealing with
it the United States has put five
billion dollars into what they call
democracy promotion in Ukraine so that's
intervention I'm sorry in the Maidan
as we now know from the Tate telephone
conversation
between the woman laughably described as
the e-news foreign minister who is to
run a chip shop in Derbyshire have never
been elected to anything in her life
Baroness Ashton we know from that
conversation between Baroness Ashton and
the Estonian Foreign Minister that the
people who were shooting snipers who
were killing people in the Maidan were
not as supposed from the previous regime
in Ukraine but well the people that we
are giving the five billion dollars to
in order to rip off the Ukrainian
Constitution drive out the president set
fire to the presidency and threatening
and beast with Monda unless they change
the constitution which involved banning
the Russian language so Russia is
responding to Western intervention in
Ukraine but you're right there is a
connection we moved in Ukraine to punish
Russia for having confounded Western
policy in Syria so yes there are no
circumstances in which the world is
entirely safe for entirely stable but I
argue it's better to have more than one
big power in the world and I just cannot
see how such educated expensively
educated men as these can't see that
well you know just swipe my expensive
education I went to my local state
school where you go George you just you
just attacked Katherine national
necessarily going to be there but in
that particular question once again
isn't there an inconsistency if you say
that China a country which is also
multi-ethnic but historically has its
own borders which should be
international respected should be one
shouldn't that be the same for Ukraine
as well which is also internationally
recognized as a single sovereign nation
with territorial borders one of the
Russia agreed as well as Thea as the
Western one of the absurdities of this
discussion is you and me sitting on a
chair in a church in here on why
lecturing China on what it should do
there's an absurdity in that you know
that China will do everything that's
necessary to keep it so sorry
together to keep foreigners out who wish
to interfere in its internal affairs and
I'm sorry that's the end of the story
but the Delta or however many Christian
fundamentalists you discover in the
Central Committee your view on China is
going to be confounded by China's
strength but the point about this is not
so much that China has an internal
strength but rather where will China be
in 10 20 30 years time in its relations
with the rest of the world and that's
the thing which I think is actually very
uncertain at this stage I wish the
Chinese themselves have way on certain
about you're talking about this as if
the Chinese are self-contained in the
colony which is in one sense I don't
know able to look after itself a
complete halt our key model there's no
doubt though that China is increasingly
heavily engaged with what's going on
elsewhere in the world I think they are
uncertain as to how to play that
engagement I stress again that when you
have this you know huge investments in
Latin America sub-saharan Africa and so
on it means that China will have to look
after those investments in the future
you can't claim that China is somehow a
separate entity that doesn't relate to
the rest of the world does inject
another points here which is
accountability now foreign policy in
democracies is determined on the whole
by the people they vote a government in
and if they don't like if they do George
if they don't like the foreign policy of
that government no food yeah well let me
finish because you think will you let me
finish that if they don't like the
foreign policy that government they will
vote it out which of course they did now
in China in and at such a certain extent
in Russia which is a pretty rigged
democracy there is no accountability for
foreign policy
it's the accountant Tony Blair is still
at large turn 125 new happiness not
since he killed a million people running
the country well you could have fooled
me
mrs. Koch was long dead but she in a way
is still running the country
your ideal are idealizing of American
and British democracy rightly provoke
wry bold laughter in the hall the
imperfection
of democracy in our countries are
mirrored of course in imperfections in
democracy in other countries but China's
no even if people in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones and I'm afraid as
an employee of Rupa I left seven years
ago get your flats right many things on
your mind you're a politician who's out
to hang the bankers and I know are you
threatening me brutal man really argues
for the threatening everyone what I've
assessed robbery yeah you and your bank
grow fat out of China but you have
nothing at all good to see about China
you're a hypocrite I'm talking nonsense
I have plenty of good things to say
about chattering if I spend most of my
time saying exactly that I think one of
the key points actually is that my point
beginning is that I disagree completely
with my friend inside the the top
echelon Safi of the Chinese communist
movement on the grounds that I don't
think China's gonna collapse I think
it's gonna muddle along actually in a
whole variety of ways
and one of the problems is that we tend
to write apocalyptic stories about the
world the United States and China
actually are very much guilty of this
because it always has to either be a
country that's gonna take over the world
or a countries are going to collapse or
fall apart under the weight of its own
contradictions the reality that we see
that the two sides are going to kind of
rub along and gather on and probably
take their own parts for quite some time
to come
I think it's less exciting but more
realistic I mean here's my take on what
I think China is going to do I think it
is not going to become a pluralist
liberal democracy anytime soon certainly
not in a 10 to 15 years I think it's
also fair to say that broadly speaking
when you talk to ordinary Chinese people
and
how much of your knowledge of China
George comes from China and talking to
Chinese people but most of my evidence
is at least empirically gathered from
actually speaking to people in China
itself in visiting so quite a lot of
people in China there aren't a lot of
people in China
I meant talk to more understand you I
have to I have to say well there are
actually something like I think what is
it 70 million Christian fundamentalists
in China and growing in in numbers but
within the wider population it's still a
smaller group they tend to also be big
business entrepreneurs actually they're
the strongest capitalists of all in in
China but the point I'm making is that
actually I think on that George is
absolutely right there is no great
enthusiasm for the idea of a change to a
liberal pluralist democratic system now
with the fact that as you'll know in
what 10 days time we have the 20th
anniversary of the Tiananmen Square
uprising a real People's Movement if
never ever was one actually George the
legacy of that is that that political
event was tragic but has not
fundamentally changed the trajectory of
where China has been going China is and
will continue to be for some time to
come a country with a neoliberal economy
much more so I think than Western Europe
these days a profoundly non democratic
authoritarian political system and one
that essentially stays unified because
it will continue to manage a steady rate
of economic growth which keeps its
people happy
essentially it's come up with the
alternative social democracy it's a form
of social dictatorship that's not really
a criticism or a compliment it's merely
a statement of I think the kind of
middle path that China's likely to take
for quite some time to come
so are we on the verge of a new world
order and if so is it simply going to be
a sort of muddled one as you say or I
mean well will China actually in
political terms start to equal the US or
even overtake the u.s. not remotely oh
this is one of the things that I think
is a great compliment to China that we
are talking about a country with a
per-capita GDP of 8,000 US dollars per
year without a source of capital they
wear quite capita but when you even in
automats 1.3 billion people it's still a
desperately poor country which actually
is much more concerned about its own
internal politics it's currently turning
as its main engine of growth to domestic
consumption now if you want people to
take more holidays if you want people to
buy more knickknacks you know plastic
goods whatever else it might be the last
thing you want to do is actually start a
war but at the same time it means I
think Stephen was getting at this but
your foreign policy is far more oriented
to keeping the domestic economy going
and smooth and stable than it is either
towards foreign adventurism on the one
hand or to finding some kind of big
major new global role in terms of being
you know the new America or the new Rome
the Chinese very much like the idea of
being thought of in those terms but when
it comes to saying yes or no on Syria on
Nigeria on the Middle East on you know a
whole variety of questions you'll find
that above all what they tend to do in
the United Nations is simply to abstain
even the veto isn't used that often
China's foreign policy taught us a great
deal but it doesn't actually do anything
very much because in the end it's still
a country thinks about the domestic
economy first I think you're right that
the chances are it's been grow steadily
over the next few years with a much
faster rate than we used to in the West
but there is never less of fear that
things would go wrong and this process
of trying to shift China away from an
export-led mccandless model as was the
case between before 2007 towards a model
which is much more based on consumption
is once been very very difficult to
achieve so far it's in lots of
investment domestically not a lot of
consumption and to get consumption
working you have to create some kind of
credit system the credit system means
opening up your your sort of capital
account your your market to the rest of
the world which other cultures have
tried to do sometimes successfully as
with a tremendous risk as you saw with
the Asian crisis back in the 1990s so
one big question I think is if things
were to go wrong in China how does the
political system cope in a period of
profound disappointment very much this
is a country that's delivered 3040 years
in the row of tremendous gains in living
standards by those who are still stuck
in rural poverty and have the hope and
the expectation will come a liberal
poverty with the next 10 20 years
it was a really big bump in the road and
no country is a immune test possibility
how does a physical system cope now one
possibility the person does gradually
evolve toward some kind of genetic model
whether it's a Western model or more
sort of Japanese Taiwanese Korean model
another possibility is that China is
tempted down might describe as a
nationalist route but actually
nationalism is one way of binding your
country together effectively trying to
blame other people for your own
difficulties and I think is worrying
both in the Asian region in terms of
nationalism growing both in China and in
Japan as we discussed I think in the
past it's also potentially worrying
because Putin has demonstrated in one
says that nationalism works at least in
the short term and I think another a
threat to the idea of a stable
multi-well and are we going to see a
more nationalist India now that Modi is
one do you think look this is one of the
things that makes one wonder about
whether or not the multipolar world is
actually going to work out or not I mean
in extremely wide-ranging and highly
democratic election India has decided to
elect someone who has a view of the
world which whatever else you can say
about it is a real departure for India
there has been clearly a BJP prime
minister before a bajpai back in the
late 90s early 2000s but this is the
first person who comes I mean George was
just criticizing Catherine Ashton for
her chip shop background well of course
mr. Modi used to sell tea in the street
and he started from that very very kind
of low background to rise to prime
ministership an amazing story in terms
of the level of mobility that is
possible in India but he brings with him
an ideology which essentially is inward
looking
it is about Hindutva it is about the
idea of some very kind of stylized
version of Hinduism which is always at
its best been a very syncretic very
inclusive type of culture you have to
look only at the emperor at burger in
the mughal period who combined Islam and
Hinduism in a whole variety of creative
ways to see that this is not the action
someone who thinks that India
realistically can play a global role he
does speak about it but I don't see how
putting forward that kind of very
nationalists very exclusively religious
defined type of identity for a syncretic
country like India can help to create
that sort of multipolar world I think
it's entirely the wrong direction in
India in particular you have a so-called
Green Revolution in the 1970s and then
the economy is transformed in a
significant way delivering much faster
growth race and all to do with
engagement rather than separation that's
although just well could I make a brief
point because one of the things that is
interesting is that one of the first
things that mr. Modi did was to issue an
invitation to know a Sharif the Prime
Minister of Pakistan to his inauguration
as Indian Prime Minister I don't know if
mr. Sharif is going to take it or up or
not but of course there is a sort of
Nixon to China type thing there that if
a very nationalist right-wing Indian
Prime Minister can make that link to
Pakistan then something that people talk
about but very little evidence for which
is the idea of a stronger set of year of
Asian unities might start to create that
kind of multi polar identity that George
was talking about earlier part of the
problem is that essentially India and
China - the big powers of the region
don't really talk to each other in a
sustained and engaged way I was stabbed
to found out just a couple of years ago
that the number of weekly flights not
daily but weekly flights between New
Delhi and Beijing to major capitals in
the Asian region is just four per week
you can't even go daily and that said
you know there's 27 a day between New
York and London for instance and that
suggests the lack of political
engagement between these two giants
which is going to be a real stepping
stone to overcome so creative diplomacy
on all sides in China India Pakistan
Iran was mentioned for as well I think
is going to be the next necessary stage
before Asia can really punch its weight
in that sense I was gonna say that one
of the big problems in that China India
have is that we think of 1962 as the
year of the Cuban Missile Crisis they
think of 1962 as the border conflict
between the two of them and they haven't
really kind of worked out how to forgive
each other for that border conflict the
Chinese affected one and life has been
very difficult in two countries since
then if you look at not just volumes of
airplanes but trade volumes
in different countries in the world one
of the biggest missed opportunities
currently is trade between China and
India both of them trade with other
parts of the world they've both been
successful but successful on their own
rather than together if he wants to have
a real sort of revolution in terms of
rising incomes riving rising living
standards over the course of the next
three or four decades I would suggest
that China and India are a pivotal part
of that story if they can open up their
trade and linkages actually exploit sort
of you know comparative advantages and
so on and so forth and also I would
suggest that both countries could hugely
benefit from helping to create what I
call us or the south south trading route
and capital flows route from Asia into
Middle East sub-saharan Africa and Latin
America but again there are difficulties
here at the so called string of pearls
which are ports open structured in
Pakistan and Myanmar and Sri Lanka and
Bangladesh which been funded largely
through Chinese money which calls the
Indians no end of uncertainty because of
course the Chinese also have the right
to put their warships able to build a
few of them put their warships into
those ports and of course the ports are
there in part to protect the journey of
energy from the Middle East through to
China but that's how the story makes the
relationship between China enjoy I think
particularly for George do you think
that
more multipolar world would become a
more equal world not necessarily not I'm
interested in it from the point of view
of equilibrium in the world but the
economic development within the
countries including the new polls of
power and influence in the world would
be a matter for them I take the
old-fashioned view that it's not
actually my business to tell other
countries how they should run their
countries I'm more interested in in how
we run ours and we're not doing that
very well so I always thought there was
a slight foolishness in the
preoccupation of our political class in
telling other countries how they should
run themselves when we are not doing a
terribly good job ourselves so that so
in 1939 you'd have been a supporter of
Neville Chamberlain would you no no I
would have been the first in line to cut
the throats of any I'm a very violent
man when it comes to mini fascist Nazi
occupation but you should have been
telling the Germans how to run their
country okay no but Germany was trying
to tell us how to run our country and I
reject that just as vehemently I went in
1939 well they were beginning to develop
foreign policy which involved invading
and dismembering other people's
countries ensuring the annihilation of
the Jewish people and gay people and
disabled people and communist people and
so on in their own country I have a
right but that was their country but
that was that country exactly no that's
not my point there are universal human
rights I saw of them and one of those
universal rights is for your people not
to be annihilated in our Holocaust so
what about human rights abuses in Russia
and China anybody human rights abuses in
Russia
and China cannot remotely be compared
unless you're Prince Charles and your I
knew you had a lot of class mine but I
didn't think you were quite in Prince
Charles's leave my son Prince Charles
compared President Putin to Hitler
I think it's an obscene comparison but
Shevin mouth Elzy counter may be useful
so great famine and people starving and
China Yuri bride was great bleep not
China no describing and your bank is
growing fat upon was created by Chairman
Mao if there was no Chairman Mao we
wouldn't be having this discussion
because China would not be a great
economic and political party your friend
dung she'll thing was the man who let
HSBC back into jail and don't let too
many of them back in if you want my
honest opinion you can have too many
bankers as we can this country no Steven
bankers dragged us to the abyss yeah and
over the egg just about humility even
wrong we require from our bankers stain
a bit of humility I just think of myself
was in the columnist you can call me
what you want I don't read minds and
your question about income wealth and
equality and how this works across
different parts of the world from here
again is that there's a connection
between countries which I think you're
ignoring the connection is a sort of
paradox of income of wealth and quality
around the world today which is that
between countries between nations income
inequality is undoubtedly for in largely
because of the strength of China and
strength of India the strength of other
country is in the so called emerging
markets over the course of the last 20
or 30 years but at the same time income
and equality within nations has risen
significantly this is something which we
haven't really seen in the past it's a
big political topic for understandable
reasons but the question I have is are
the two in some sense connected I think
they are and the connection is that one
of the big revolutions that we've seen
in the global economy over the last 30
or 40 years is the cross-border mobility
of capital
money moving across borders I accept
that bankers are partly responsible for
this of course the money moving across
borders in many ways creating
opportunities for countries to grow more
quickly than would otherwise be the case
if you say well what was the sort of
single most important reform from Deng
Xiaoping in 1980s it was opening up
China for business with the rest of the
world not just Russia to Mao but rutted
to the China over the last four or five
hundred previous years is an absolute
revolution a problem with happen on the
book mobility is that capital goes often
to where labor is rosalie cheap so lots
of capital that might have been invested
in the states might have been invested
in Europe went to China and the
consequence was that Chinese wages rose
swiftly there's lots of urbanization
China grew very quickly but at the same
time the bargaining position of labor in
the US and in the UK in Europe went down
now that's a very tricky issue for us to
think about because at the sovereign
level at the individual level you get
higher it levels of income inequality
but at the global level you end up with
a bigger increase in the living stand as
we've seen ever before and I think
there's a really big contradiction which
politically is very difficult to deal
with in terms of individual countries
absolutely I mean I think one of the
reasons why I mean again George makes a
very central and very important point
about why on earth should we be in any
position to tell any other country how
to run themselves and actually I didn't
think we are in a position to do that
but I do think we're in a position to
have to care about how other countries
run themselves just to stick with China
for a moment if some of the things that
are going on in the East China Sea at
the moment where China's can concern for
non-interference and territorial
sovereignty seems to be a little more
flexible certain in terms of possession
of islands placed equidistantly between
Japan and China in those seas which
could trigger not I think necessary
through intention but through
carelessness a conflict between second
and third largest economies in the world
if that were to come off if the whole of
that area were to go off into flames I
think it would affect economies all
across the world including our own and
that is a subject I think of quite
legitimate concern for all of us now it
doesn't mean we can be in a position to
get on the phone and tell anyone in
Beijing what to do not least because as
he points out they went to answer it
they would have take the call but at the
same time it doesn't mean we shouldn't
be thinking about ways in which our
increasingly integrated world shouldn't
try and avoid those sorts
of conflicts and the fact is that some
of that will involve having to engage
with countries and telling them they
cannot have completely autonomous
choices about how they operate their
foreign policy I'd really like to thank
you for coming to runner to Steven and
to George for speaking and please show
your appreciation
[Applause]
you